yeah I think it would be really really
ignorant to say that there are not
people out there who do worship the
devil who do worship these deities
I have been so confused by Balenciaga
not not really by the symbols that
they're showing not really by the fact
that they're pushing the weird sex stuff
and and even the Satanism but I've been
confused by it because I don't know
anything about high fashion or runways
or anything I thought what is going on
in these board rooms what is going on in
these design teams that would actually
convince you that you should put an S M
teddy bear and a sad looking little kid
and and some caution tape that says bow
the the most well-known demon probably
of all time in your shoot and that's
gonna fly how could you convince
yourself that that's gonna fly what do I
know that's why I had to bring some
models on to help explain it to me we
welcome back to the show Lauren smoker
they passed Miss Hollywood who has
competed in both the Miss America and
Miss USA organizations and has done
Runway work for Giovanni Fashions and
other closing Brands Maria Montgomery we
welcome back to the show former Miss
Kentucky USA runner-up to Miss USA uh
who has done all sorts of modeling and
has walked the runway for marchesa and
Isaac Mizrahi I was this close to
walking the runway for those guys but
they didn't I it was I was a runner-up
and then we welcome to the show for the
first time Grace Smith who is another
model who has done work for all sorts of
household Brands well-known Brands
Hermes nizolo lots of others as well
ladies thank you so much for being on
the show of course so excited to be back
yes thanks for having us Lauren I want
to start with you I remember I was
watching I guess it was the Balenciaga
fashion show before all this weird Satan
stuff blew up and I was looking at all
the models walk around and it looked
like they were walking around in trash
bags and sort of Darth Vader robes and
just kind of weird dark muddy ugly stuff
and I thought wait hold on if this is
high fashion if this is supposed to be
the height of beauty I must be missing
something
well I feel like with Balenciaga it is a
very different brand than even a lot of
other high-end Brands I personally have
never worn it
um but I have a lot of friends who are
in the high-end fashion world and what
they had to say about it is it is a very
um it has a very artistic take on
clothing that a lot of high-end Brands
typically don't have so again it's it's
things that I typically would not wear
but um everybody who I have talked to
who does wear it who does is attracted
to the brand
um likes the artistic take that they
take on a lot of their designs but I'm
not opposed to Artistic things I love
the paintings of Raphael and Titian and
Michelangelo and my problem with
valenciaga is that the art that they are
putting out there is is not beautiful
it's it's ugly it's seemingly
intentionally and offensively
ugly and grotesque Maria why would a
fashion brand that is supposed to appeal
to people and attract people and they
hire all these beautiful women to put on
clothing why would they put them in such
ugly clothing
yeah that's a question I've been asking
myself for 14 years of modeling now
um but I think the biggest thing is
everyone just wants publicity any
publicity sometimes can be seen as good
publicity because now we're talking
about it even in the more cases show
that you referenced previously they had
us with crazy hair teased out the Wazoo
massive things that you would just never
wear in real life
um and all I think sometimes we lose
sight of what is attractive and what is
flattering in order to make a statement
and I think this is a prime example of
when that has gone way too far of course
I and and people are attracted to
attention at all costs so then is it is
what you're saying that it's very
difficult to make beautiful things
and get attention for making beautiful
things but it's much easier rather to
make ugly things and if you put a trash
bag on your head and start holding up
Satan puppets that you know you'll get
attention and it's pretty easy to do it
is that what you're saying
Sally I guess so I think so many people
are just after that attention but at the
same time they may have one pretty piece
in the whole collection and then that
The Crazy Ones are what drive you in to
look at the the one pretty one even
though you don't see people wearing
these things down the street yes there
are great items from any High fashion
designer but there's a time and a place
for those things nine times out of ten
those statement pieces that are a little
crazy
um which Balenciaga is very known for
especially just in their styling of the
runway shows with walking through mud
and things like that
um I think it's just mostly about making
a statement and then you come to them to
purchase the more realistic items of
their collection so I guess the most
interesting thing to me is how
unsurprised both of you have been I look
at this even before the weird pedo Satan
stuff I'm looking at the mud fashion
show I'm saying what on Earth but what
you you seem non-plussed by you seem to
say well you know that's just Balenciaga
that's what they do Grace were you
surprised at all with this story coming
out of Balenciaga
yeah unfortunately no I wasn't surprised
but I was a little sad especially given
um the history of Balenciaga it's one of
the most notable brands starting back in
1919 so no not shocked for where we are
today but it is kind of sad to see kind
of the downturn
so it's a downturn of the brand do you
think it's a downturn of high fashion
generally
yeah I think we could probably
confidently say that at this point I
think there's just a lack of
appreciation for true beauty and true
art these days and you see that in our
modern architecture our Modern Art and
now we're seeing that in our fashion so
it's a sad day I guess so what caused if
if we're saying here that
fashion used to be
more oriented toward Beauty and used to
be more normal and wasn't always pushing
s m teddy bears and little kids and
little ball tape then what changed
Lauren do you have any thoughts well I I
definitely with this campaign that came
out I absolutely think there was an
agenda being pushed and I anyone who
thinks otherwise I would like to think
there's just a naive aspect there in
their thought process but this is
something where a ton of thought goes
into this we know this we're we're in
the modeling industry we're in that
we're artists we're actors we we know
that prep goes into this thought goes
into this countless meetings countless
calls of uh storyboards uh does this
look okay how do you what do you think
about this
um I would love to be in one of these
meetings prior to this campaign and see
if anybody said anything if anybody
questioned that this isn't normal and my
concern is that this isn't just the
conditioning of children but the fact
that more adults have not spoken up this
is the fact that this is shows how many
adults are now conditioned in our day
and age to think that this is normal
behavior and normal fashion that's a
great point the fact that we're all just
sort of numb to this or many people are
numb to this shows you just how how
effective this sort of campaign has been
and to your point I'm glad you affirmed
for me my suspicion that the Balenciaga
excuse of oh Whoopsie Daisy yeah we just
did we should have had a little more
oversight you know sometimes it happens
you set up a photo shoot and an s m
teddy bear just walks on and a little
kid is frowning and we have references
to Satan and ball and child pornography
it's just like oh just our luck you know
that that all just coincidentally
happened at the same time Maria if if
you're in the meeting and and you're
sitting around the table you're you're
talking to some people there's this guy
demna something or other there was this
other stylist who was working at with
Balenciaga and you look at some of their
work and a lot of their work even Beyond
Balenciaga gets very very dark number of
people have gone to their Instagram
pages and seen just weird Fascinations
with all sorts of depraved sexual acts
and overt satanic imagery and it's going
back a long long time so it wasn't just
from this photo shoot so who are these
people who are the people who are who
are designing these shows and you know
on a scale from just an accident and a
coincidence to Alex Jones these are
demons meeting in the woods to turn the
freaking frogs gay like where does this
fall on that scale
well I think the most important thing to
consider is how many people are on a set
like this so even for any smaller
campaigns that I have even shot for
there are no less than 15 people on set
physically that does not include the
Post photo shoot where there's editing
where there's light adjustments
um and the multiple approving process
even if I just do a social media
influencing campaign for a brand I have
to get approval before I post it and or
before they post it and then same thing
with modeling like I said that that
shoot is intensive and especially a
brand like lindsayaga this is not a
small budget this is a big big shoot and
these shoots are not an e-commerce shoe
this is not what happens Monday through
Friday like a lot of more so department
store type Brands shoot this is a a big
scheduled thing and way in advance and
then these photos get multiple sets of
approval so there is a yes a stylist
there's probably a stylist assistant
there's a designer there's a
photographer photographer assistant and
just to think that
um that this didn't get caught and I I
agree Lauren I want to assume that they
were naive and that it was just a
mistake and they missed it but someone
said they brought the go to in addition
to the Adidas collaboration where they
brought the court document of the child
pornography that I got slipped in there
by accident from a proper room well
I mean that just goes to further the
case of there's just too many variables
here that are matching up but this can't
be a mistake that whether someone maybe
on the crew decided to do this and
hopefully didn't get caught and they're
now happy that it's out there or or
maybe it was an agreeance I we don't
know obviously and I just I can't
understand what they would think and I
would hope that this isn't true that I
would think publicity is good even if in
the side of child pornography this is
what I don't understand is you know
there's that thesis which is well they
just you know all presses good press and
they just wanted to make a splash and
shock people and there's pretty much
nothing more shocking than child
pornography so that's what we're gonna
do or given the backlash
were they just trying to sneak it in
it's not as though that Court Document
referencing a child pornography case
from actually another child pornography
case it's not as though that we're so
obvious it was you know you kind of had
to zoom in and look at the text of it
it's not as though this child were
actually you know splayed out in some
overtly sexual position it was a little
more subtle with you know it was he was
holding a teddy bear with the weird the
weird sex costume on I mean so I'm using
subtle in a liberal way but what I'm
telling you is it wasn't totally 100 in
your face so then the other thesis is
were they just trying to slip in a kind
of subtle almost subliminal message and
hope that they would not be caught Grace
what do you think
yeah that's really hard to say I think
there have been a lot of subtle things
happening in the fashion industry for
decades at this point so yes it could
have been a subtle hint
um they could have you know been more
purposeful
um and what they were placing there it's
it's really hard to say but
I kind of tend to go with you have to
call a spade a spade and if it was there
most most likely it was intentionally
there yeah certainly intentional I just
wonder if they were trying for their
message to be consciously understood or
if this were part of a broader campaign
as Lauren you referenced of people just
in in indoctrinating the whole culture
such that even the adults become numb to
it and even the adults say oh well
what's wrong here oh it's child s m I
didn't even notice it you know and they
just sort of move on and on so if the
industry has gotten this bad
have have you seen this in your personal
experience I mean have you seen this as
you're doing runways as you're doing uh
photo shoots or is this something where
you you know you you look at you say oh
no it's just it's really just Balenciaga
maybe it trickles down but it's it's not
it hasn't made it all the way down to
all the other brands as well Lauren uh
well I I personally haven't seen a whole
lot of it I I've been in the industry a
very long time but I was not as a child
and I can't help but think maybe this is
one of the reasons why my parents didn't
want me to get too much into the
industry when I was younger uh which I
very much respect them for now
um but what's very interesting about
this when I was doing some research on
it so many of the first articles that
came up when I just Googled
Balenciaga conspiracy or Balenciaga
controversy the first articles that came
up where this controversy spirals white
right wing conspiracy theorists and and
what blows my mind is that this is
something that anything involving
children and a sexual topic the fact
that that is a conspiracy theory that's
the hill that I'm willing to die on
anything that involves children right
well and and you bring up a great point
the way that this was covered in the
Press was not Balenciaga does this
shocking terrible thing it was
conservatives pounce the conspiracy
theorists are making you know a mountain
out of a molehill but we know that that
wasn't the case because Balenciaga came
out immediately
scrubbed its Instagram page threatened
to sue for tens of millions of dollars
the people who allegedly were behind the
shoot that now they've actually
withdrawn that lawsuit because I suspect
they realize that they can't just blame
this on some photographer
runs a marketing company they realized
that it was their own creative directors
their own stylists who were behind a lot
of this stuff and so now they're just
but they're obviously taking them very
very seriously so you could see a
contradiction between the liberal press
lying and saying oh it's not a big deal
you're just making something out of
nothing and Balenciaga is saying no this
is a huge deal and we're gonna take
legal action against the people who were
behind it Maria I mean do you do you
find this to be a widespread phenomenon
in the industry
um I agree I I don't necessarily again a
lot of my brains that I shoot for
regularly are Beauty Brands and more
household Brands not so much the
high-end editorial which I also have
kind of designed my career to be shaping
that direction on purpose to avoid
situations like this so
um I just think regardless it's it's how
you what you choose and what you again
like you reference what you allow and
what we begin to get used to and I hope
that's not the way the this industry is
going but at the end of the day whether
they are claiming that they didn't know
ignorance is not an excuse like I said
there's way too many people to approve
this campaign before it goes public so
and that includes zooming in to read a
document that's not hard we can do that
on our iPhone so why why is it hard for
a marketing agency to think to do that
and again this is not one shoot out of
100 that they did that week this is a
big campaign and so a lot of time it
ever went into this and so whether they
want to pretend that they didn't see it
it or whether people were behind it and
trying to give us that subconscious
notion of this this dark side it's not a
left or right argument it's instead just
children involved and that's never okay
I'm relieved to hear you say that it
hasn't really trickled down to some of
the more normal popular brands because
it really ties into something that I've
noticed for a long time which is that
most people are basically normal but for
whatever reason the people at the very
very tippy top of our political system
of our media of our academic
institutions of all the people the the
ruling Elite you know they tend to be
nuts I mean they tend to believe some
really kooky crazy things if you look at
the transiting the kids movement right
now
80 probably 90 plus of Americans
strongly oppose that so why are we
hearing so much about it because the
people in power are super into it and
this is true when you talk about you
know legalizing abortion in all cases 94
of Americans don't think that abortion
should be legal in all cases but the the
people who are at the top of so many
institutions they're the ones who are
pushing it they're the the radical
people the the people that Senator John
Kennedy in his Foghorn Leghorn voice
says are the they're the high Q stupid
people and so I just have to wonder what
is wrong
with these people at the very tippy top
that they would push this satanic
imagery Grace what do you think is it is
it that
this is the satanic weird leather chains
dungeon kind of imagery the ball
references are it's just a way to be
kind of edgy like you know online
atheists or something like that it's
just kind of cheeky and shocking or do
you think that these people actually
have a spiritual and religious
fascination with
with the Devil
yeah I think it would be really really
ignorant to say that there are not
people out there who do worship the
devil who do worship these deities I
think one of um Satan's best tricks that
he's ever played is to convince the
world that he doesn't exist and that
he's more of a caricature than an actual
you know Spirit or you know whatever you
believe him to be
so can I accuse these people of being
demon worshipers maybe not but at the
same time I would always just call a
spade a spade and if this is the kind of
thing that they're putting out into
their work then most likely this is
something that's deeply connected to
their heart so
unfortunately I agree with you you seem
quite confident though in saying no
they're actually listening you secular
liberals there actually are people who
worship the devil there actually are
people who worship demons do you have
some experience with this have you seen
this or is this just your intuition
yeah I I'm actually so I'm born and
raised in Nashville but my mom is from a
small island above Venezuela and so
there is a lot of Supernatural stuff
that happens on the island my mom has
had confrontations with what she would
say are maybe demons she's seen them um
there's just a lot of spiritual activity
happening there so I can confidently say
that it's real it exists and I think the
western church has done a great job at
downplaying it and making it seem as so
it doesn't
huh you know what's funny because that's
that's an amazing story and you always
hear about Voodoo and all sorts of
Witchcraft and things and in some of
these cultures and uh but you're saying
no my mother actually has seen it you
know it's it's kind of a common thing
and I totally believe it I'm I'm with
Anton and Scalia on this point who once
said to A pompous ignorant interviewer
who was shocked that he believed in God
and was a Catholic he said you know I
even believe in the devil he said many
many more intelligent people than you
and I have believed in the devil and
believed that the devil exists and some
people go further and worship him and
I'm inclined to believe what what uh
you're saying grace which is that
you know if you if you constantly use
this kind of imagery the the pentagrams
and red horns and the ball and this and
that and you're doing and you're using
images that have cropped up for all of
human history and you're sort of
ironically worshiping the devil as many
of these edgy leftist people try to do
well if you do that ironically forever
it's not ironic anymore you can't
ironically worship somebody forever
you're just you're just ultimately doing
it sincerely in the fact that very
high-end fashion not even just regular
kind of middle of the pack but that very
high-end Elite fashion they're engaged
in all these kinds of creepy outright
occult kinds of practices and symbols is
perhaps not surprising but it is a bit
of a cause for alarm ladies thank you
for coming back and helping me to
understand this topic that I will admit
I've never walked the fashion runway
Lauren smoker Maria Montgomery Ray Smith
just going down the line where can we
find your
uh you can find me Lauren Smolka on
Instagram and you can find me just at
Maria Montgomery on Instagram as well
and you can find me at Grace th Smith on
Instagram as well and you can find me on
the Michael Knowles show I'm Michael
nolsis Michael Noel show we'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]